foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
getting to results faster Automation and
miltony biotech Imaging workflows this
webinar is a part of the sixth annual
laboratory automation virtual event
I'm Angelina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and sponsored by
miltony biotech for more information
about miltony biotech please go to
miltonybiotech.com
now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click submit
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
or just use the ask a question box to
let us know you need help
you will also notice that the speaker
has provided a survey located to the
right of the abstract
this survey will be available during
both the live session and the on-demand
period
in addition to asking questions we
encourage you to participate in three
poll questions
to participate simply click on the
option that best describes your answer
we appreciate your participation
our first polling question is are you
looking to expand your Imaging
capabilities
select all that apply
yes I have batch High throughput Imaging
needs
yes I need to image large intact tissues
yes I'm looking to deeply characterize
the cells within my biological system
that question again is are you looking
to expand your Imaging capabilities
I'll give you a few moments to select
your answers
our next question is does your current
Imaging protocol include any of the
following
I am performing large cell analysis
I spend a large portion of my time
validating if antibodies
I spend a lot of time clearing tissues
that question again is does your current
Imaging protocol include any of the
following
please take a few moments to select your
answers
and our final question is after watching
this webinar would you like to request
more information
yes I'd like to schedule a call with the
miltony biotech Imaging expert
yes I'd like to receive a brochure on
miltony biotech's Imaging Solutions
or no not at this time
the question again is would you like to
request more information
thank you so much for participating in
those polling questions
I would not like to now present today's
speaker Dr Amy jablonski technology and
application specialists at miltony
biotech for a complete biography honor
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the left of your screen
Dr jablonski you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction and for
answering those poll questions so I'm
really excited to talk about miltoni
biotech Imaging workflows
um and really how we're really getting
you know working with researchers so
that we can find a more efficient and
reliable way for them to get their data
out now while this certainly concludes
or automation we have a whole list of
other features and tools built in to
make the barrier to getting you know
Imaging done lower and allow the
researcher to really focus on what
matters and in this case the data output
certainly there's all sorts of you know
animation that can be used to explore
biological systems you know whether it's
the creation of certain models or
staining of cells these are all things
that you maybe you've already had
experience with now these uh you know
even are frequently used in a whole host
of multi-ohmic approaches like I'm
showing here right to really deeply
understand biology so definitely we've
got you know just an example of say a
tumor environment that we would want to
understand you know we could use
genomics metabolomics or transcriptomics
or even where we're going to be talking
and focusing most in is the proteomic
space and each of these has a slew of
established and some emerging
Technologies
um that really are able to generate the
data that you would need out of that now
you know in the world of proteomics
which is where I'm going to be spending
most of the talk today uh you know there
are some really common techniques you
know that you've even used and probably
even used some Automation in including
that of the elizas and flow cytometry so
the really nice thing is about these
techniques is that you can really
increase the throughput
um and get a lot of information out in a
short amount of time now though when we
think about it in the Imaging space you
know things like immunohistochemistry
and immunofluorescence
um you know automation is just really
getting going here however if you think
about it Imaging you know based spatial
technologies have really emerged as a
exceptionally powerful and versatile
tool for assessing relevant spatial
characteristics in biology so we'll
we'll jump in and talk a little bit more
about that throughout the talk so you
know this really includes the whole
gamut of of you know ranges of
biological uh scales here we definitely
could be talking on something on the you
know larger scale like a whole Mouse
being able to understand the spatial
information of certain organs where sort
and tumors are in that Mouse we
definitely can then move into something
a little bit smaller so we could do you
know Imaging of a mouse heart rate
understanding the relationships of of
what's going on in that this could even
be smaller and a lot of you maybe even
have worked with creating organoids as
model systems and being able to image
kind of what makes up this and use it as
a model system for certain biology but
then we can even go all the way down to
the Single Cell level as we've got here
an example of looking at a tumor sorry a
tertiary lymphoid structure staying with
a lot of different markers so people
understand kind of the characteristics
of what makes that up in their
interaction with all of those as well
so does it here it meltini we really
recognize the need or the range of
Imaging Solutions to tackle all these
type of biological questions that may be
able to come out of this you know
understanding spatial interactions in
the biology across you know all of these
different scales from the macroscopic
you know with our large animals down to
the single cell or microscopic level as
well and I like to really refer to them
as Solutions because it's not just the
instrumentation obviously you've got
some images and we'll be talking about
the automation
um in kind of the efficiency in these
instrumentations however it really is
the whole workflow like we said to be
able to get to that data output even
faster
so you know I'm going to be focusing on
two aspects of that and I'm going to be
focusing on both the light sheet
microscopy and then also the high
content side and so I'm going to
actually start here with the light sheet
fluorescence microscopy now some of you
have many or may have already used this
particular technique in different
platforms however I'd like to kind of
just spend a few minutes explaining what
goes on in this particular technique so
that we can appreciate where we put in
the automation later on
so for example I am just using this
zebrafish in the center of the screen
labeled with different floorboards so
the little uh Stars inside there and in
light sheet microscopy right the
excitation and the detection pass are
actually uncoupled and oriented
perpendicular to each other so this is
represented by the two objectives or the
purple outlines on your screen
so the excitation beam actually
illuminates the sample from the side and
the detection of the fluorescent so now
we've got a couple of the little stars
inside of the zebrafish lighting up that
these are actually detected on the
vertical axis so we saw that that
emission path now is on that lower
portion of of the zebrafish so the
really nice thing about this is that the
excitation beam can propagate through
the width of the sample and therefore
the light sheet itself is creating the
optical section compared to some other
technologies that you may be familiar
with
this means that there's no requirement
um for blocking out of focus light so
thus you get a little more efficiency
here
um you know and on top of that we have
no amplification of the signal with
certain pmts instead you know like cheap
microscopes are really able to acquire
that entire field of view in a single
camera frame and then if you combine
this with being able to do the absolute
translation so this would be you know
either moving the sample through the
beam or moving the beam through the
sample you know this is able to then
really quickly generate a 3D volume of
the biology that you're Imaging
and that's when you combine this with
tissue clearing right lychee microscopy
allows the Imaging of a large range of
sample sizes so certainly you know if we
look on the screen right we've kind of
got our our range of what we would be
looking at and then some different
Imaging Technologies uh listed below now
certainly you know there are ones that
are better suited for those that are
smaller however if you want to be able
to start moving closer to that larger
range of say rodent organs and small
animals right this is where we really
can then you know hit you know get past
that wall that I'm I'm showing with
certain things like multi-photon and
confocal to be able to get past that
right and overcome these certain
challenges that they may get in order to
be able to get into those so not only
are you Imaging you know small uh
samples such as drosophila brains or
organoids like we showed you an example
right that are really really common
income Google workflows you you know we
can then
um be able to get past that image all
the way to the organs and the small
animals where really can focal usability
has been decreased
so this brings in advantages you know a
series of advantages to the light sheet
microscopy
um including the ones that you see on
your screen first uh really gentle with
minimal folded bleaching right because
we have the excitation being propagating
the width of the sample we're able to
use that to create the optical section
of interest and so we don't have to
raster and have a lot of light going to
it second as you saw on the previous
slide you know when we combine light
sheet microscopy long working distance
objectives and tissue clearing this
allows for a wide range of samples that
otherwise would be you know need to be
optically sectioned to be able to
investigate
and then not only that we've really got
fast acquisition time so because we're
not having that requirement of blocking
out of focus light with a pinhole or
scanning across a field of view to
acquire the signal with pmts the light
microscope really can achieve these
faster acquisition times and still be
able to resolve individual cells
so this is made lychee microscopy a
method used across various fields of
science including that of Neuroscience
and immuno oncology to really visualize
these larger 3D samples organs in small
animals as you can see in the covers
displayed on the screen here now those
of you that have done like cheap
microscopy know that there is a lot more
to just Imaging the samples and being
able to produce images like this you
know there's a you know to achieve these
types of cover art there are a couple of
considerations in Sample preparation in
imaging conditions
and this is where military biotech takes
really a holistic approach right we're
talking about being able to you know
really get these
um you know conditions done and
optimized uh efficiently so that you can
get to the point of Imaging um and
looking at the data and so you know
we're really trying to decrease that
barrier so that researchers can focus on
the data output in their scientific
outcomes
so to begin we've got the you know the
biggest challenge
um that people usually face is when
staining thick uh sections or entire
organs it's really the complete
penetration or diffusion of the
antibodies through the entire sample so
to ease this burden we have uh 3D if
validated antibodies
um that have been screened for
functionality and optimized for tissue
penetration now you can observe this in
the image on the right um of a cerebral
organoid stain with beta 3 tubulin in
the case of the military biotech 3dif
antibody the antibody has penetrated
deeper reaching the center of the
organoid so that distinct features
um can be seen whereas if you compare
that to the image on the left side we
can see that there is not as much
penetration this impairs the actual
Imaging that we could be done in this
also these are recommodly engineered
reaffinity antibodies they're directly
conjugated to Bright and photos stable
viodize so this offers a lot of
advantages of direct immunofluorescent
staining including reducing the stain
during time a great signal the
background ratio and then also minimal
background signals as compared to
indirect staining
the next consideration is the tissue
clearing that you heard me talk about
before in normal live or fixed tissue
different materials within the tissue
including things like water proteins and
lipids impair the light passage so you
can see this kind of in the middle in
the schematic of a simplified view of
tissue and all the materials that would
be kind of causing things like
reflection refraction scattering and
absorption and this really decreases the
light penetration detection and
ultimately the image quality so that's
why you get something like the image on
the right of this brain and it's very
opaque so you know the goal of tissue
clearing is to render the tissue
transparent to reduce these impairments
for better Imaging so specific protocols
have been developed using the max
clearing kit for easy fast and effective
immunostaining and support
um of different tissues however the
system is not limited only to this kit
you know that has the flexibility and
support to handle different kinds of
clearing methods as well that you may
already be working with
and last is the inter instrumentation to
visualize the actual samples so in
combination with you know our Cutting
Edge uh like micro uh light sheet
illumination technology and objective
lenses to ensure this image quality
across all the scales you know this to
be able to create the the 3D Volume of
your sample now there are a lot of
different unique features uh an
automation that's been built in with
this that I'm going to talk about in the
next couple of slides that really I
think lend itself to the ease of use
flexibility and quality of Imaging
so we're gonna go ahead and start with
the actual light sheath Optics
themselves so the ultra microscope is
actually equipped with six light sheets
three on the left and three on the right
so if you think about this if you only
have one light sheet going through a
very you know even a clear tissue you
might get something like the image on
the bottom right hand corner however by
adding these different light sheets you
know from the left and the right you get
a much more homogeneous illumination
better sectioning and then even better
image quality
the other thing is is that we have the
system has three long working distance
lenses to reside on the scope there's no
need for the researcher to really kind
of decide which one would be best for
all the samples that they may want to
image this also has a lens exchanger for
applying demagnification and
post-magnification capabilities of 0.6 X
up to 30X to really give you the
versatility of each of those objectives
on the system as well
additionally these objectives are fully
automated you just simply go ahead and
you can add a touch of a button you can
change them to the one you want and then
automatically find the sample so that
you're really streamlining the Imaging
process
and then last but not least is the large
automated sample chamber for easy access
and mounting of multiple samples which
we're going to take a look at in the
next slide
so let's go ahead and
let's watch this quick movie so how did
you know basically we're able to Simply
um release and then Mount samples into
the Imaging chamber like you saw at the
beginning of the movie so this could be
a whole mouse or a series of organs and
now what you see is that we're actually
once you've loaded it in right you've
got this bad acquisition that can be set
up to automate the acquisition as you're
seeing let's go through each of these
different types of organisms or organs
um so that really again you're able to
set all this up ahead of time get these
images done and then in the end just
take that data off
so in the next simple slides I just want
to show you a little bit of examples of
what can be you know image with this
system right to be able to get an idea
of like the image quality and and the
types of of data that you could get out
of it so we're going to first start with
the
um with looking at something on a scale
of a couple of of
um microns
um so this is a brain organoid in this
example
uh we can see uh Ki 67 here in yellow
followed by the Sox II in magenta and
the neuronal marker in beta 3 tubulin
and cyan
in the next example we're going to go
ahead and actually look at something a
little bit larger now we're going to be
looking at a whole Mouse heart so kind
of the context of this is if you're
thinking about restoration of perfusion
after acute mitochondrial infarction you
know this is the most frequent and
effective medical treatment however
there during this process it may
actually inflict an eschema reperfusion
injury or IR injury which you'll see as
the movie is going through and that the
Hallmark of this injury is laws of
vasculature and extensive inflammatory
response
so now has this movie plays through
we're going to be able to see using 3D
analysis really allowed the researchers
to simultaneously characterize the
extent and localization of the damage
and ensuing inflammatory responses in
the whole heart so that's what's kind of
being rendered here and the other thing
is is that they could look at acute and
late vascular IR damage zones and these
had really highly localized and
spatially structured neutrophil
infiltrates that were you know
identified with the ly6g Positive spots
or the cells that you saw in the video
so moving along to now you know the lobe
of a lung of a mouse lung so in this
example they were looking at a human
innate lymphoid cells and in the context
of
um mucosal inflammation so in the video
that you're going to see this is
actually a 3D animation of reconstructed
lung lobes after 24 hours after the IV
transfer of labeled human ilc2 into the
mouse
with induced lung inflammation
as we see these rendered through you'll
also see that there are these red spots
those are actually the accumulated human
ilc2s inside of this mouse lung here
that they were able to then quantify and
kind of get a better picture of what was
going on within this system
and the last example is actually a very
interesting one again this is looking at
a whole mouse body so you know
underneath the kind of it's a little
icon of a mouse you'll see that there
was indeed a full mouse that was
um cleared and that's what it looks like
now what we're doing in here is like the
the researchers are looking for a very
reliable detection of disseminated tumor
cells and the biodistribution of certain
tumor targeting uh therapeutic
antibodies within this entire body so
the idea being is that being able to see
the entire Mouse and all the the you
know the the different biodistribution
of the uh cancer metathesis this allows
them to better understand what's going
on with their system
so as we fly through the mouse here
you'll see kind of in Gray just the
regular autofluorescence the blue is
each of the organs and then in the
magenta that you saw these are the
different
um you know the metatheses of the
different cancer and so what you're
seeing now is like a zoom in of some of
these micro metastases of various sizes
throughout the entire mouth and that's
what they're trying to Target with the
antibiotic the therapeutic antibody
treatment so now as we're looking at it
you'll see the targeted tumors are
actually in white the uncomated tumors
are in magenta and we can see that there
is a difference in you know there are
some that obviously have been targeted
but there are still some that are not
targeted throughout the mouths and the
thing that they were interested in is
you know why is that and so what they
had to do in this particular case is
that they excise these micro metaphyses
they section them and then use confocal
to kind of look at different the sizes
and the code clustering with some of the
the different markers that they were
able to look at but the conclusion that
they had was that the existence of
certain factors in the tumor micro
environment were really influencing the
efficiency of the antibody drug uh
targeting
so that's not too surprising when you
think start to consider all that goes
into the tumor microenvironment you know
while the tumor cells are definitely a
key constituency of the tissue masses
they're also surrounded by a complex
microenvironment that comprises of a
mixture of stromal cells immune cells
cytokines and extracellular proteins
so each of these populations you know if
we're looking at a top level of these
different immune cells uh kind of in the
orange boxes the idea is is that it's
not just these particular cells and
underneath all of these there's a sub
population or sub uh types within each
one of these as well and there are
different abundances and also spatial
locations that make up the tumor
microenvironment and as we saw on the
previous example right each of these
cell populations really can make have
differences
um across the macroscopic and the
microscopic scale of these tissues and
contribute to the unpredictability of
some cancer treatments and so that's
really kind of where we came in thinking
that there's a need for appropriate
Technologies and techniques to
understand the multiple facets of this
tumor microenvironment
so you know there's really been a a push
to better characterize the tumor
microenvironment uh there's been lots of
methods that have been used to go across
you know the number of markers that you
may need to be able to classify that so
in this case you know there are things
like flow cytometry has been used a very
high throughput efficient way of being
able to do
um fast analysis of single cells on a
very high marker
um kind of context however by doing flow
cytometry you you normally have to do
something like dissociation right to be
able to get those individual cells to be
able to analyze and this loses all the
spatial information that you would have
gotten you know had you kept the tumor
intact and as we saw you know there is
also this facial distribution and the
interaction between these that we want
to be able to investigate as they might
play a role in what's going on in this
case as well
and that's where really you know there
the Imaging side or some you know very
common immunoh chemical methods
um have played an important role in that
they keep the spatial distribution or
the straight the spatial makeup of
um of the tissue however compared to
what you can experience and flow is that
it up to this point it had been very
limited in the number of channels or the
markers that you could use and on top of
that if you were doing multiplexing in
the immunohistochemical you know
traditional uh space this would require
not only serial sectioning but also a
lot of um you know Hands-On time of
being able to do all these subsequent
stainings and so that's where really you
know we we've introduced the maximum
Imaging cyclic staining or mixed for
shorts so you'll hear me refer to this a
leader in the talk but that basically we
are going to be able to do all of this
staining right be able to get past the
number of like the four or six markers
um that we were seeing with kind of the
traditional approaches but in a very
hands-off way to be able to get past
that number
um and really get this done quickly
so in the mix technology we have just a
little like icon of our particular
instrument there we've basically put in
prepared tissue that has no markers on
it we then the first step is to stain
with up to three fluorescent um
antibodies so I just got an example of
say cd30 326 uh cd31 and CD4 is the
first go-around we then the next step in
this would be able to sequentially image
these fluorescent antibodies along with
dappy
and then do the last step which is erase
that signal and basically prep the
sample to be able to have the next a
round of antibodies applied so we can
see we'll go for another round we've got
cd45 Ro we've got uh collagen four we've
got some other markers in here as well
we do the subsequent uh uh
uh sorry the Imaging of those and then
we're able to do an array step again
so you can see that basically we will
continue building this up for the number
of markers that we need and the cyclic
kind of approach and you know you go
until the number of antibodies that you
needed to reach for your particular
question now our record is 400
um however we you know do a lot up to
hundreds of markers because that's you
know what we need to be able to define
the system that we're working with
and so if we think about it there's a
lot of advantages to doing it in this
method versus say you know the methods
we talked about at the beginning here so
we definitely can get hundreds of
markers on a single piece of tissue so
we're not having to do a lot of Serial
sectioning which can be very you know
um it's not always possible when you are
working with rare tissue additionally
unlike flow cytometry where you're
dissociating the tissue to be able to
then put it into the flow cytometer
you'd be able to identify each of those
cells we keep the spatial distribution
along those single cells so now we're
really able to start looking at those
spatial interactions that we might have
lost
and then on top of that this is a
non-destructive process so in theory
once you've been able to do this you
could use it for other Downstream
Technologies uh on again a rare piece of
tissue
and so here's just another example of
just kind of what we can achieve with
the mixed technology definitely we've
got a couple of different Publications a
nice one looking at both the proteomic
but also the transcriptomic space and
correlating those
um some and then also some in the
immunotherapy space and at the very end
of this talk we'll actually dive into
how all these things come together
um to be able to to do that last um one
on the right uh looking at uh pancreatic
adenocarcinoma and car T therapy
so again being able to bring this all
together for the researchers so that
they can worry more about the actual
data output we've come up with this
solution of you know what I call four
pillars to be able to get this done you
know in a rapid and efficient way first
is definitely the fully automated
instrument
so this is uh all built together
um to be fully automated for the sample
processing and the Imaging so this
includes you know having multiple spots
to be able to put the number of samples
that you want to image in there also to
have a um the reagent plate in here and
this is the only place that basically
the researcher would be interacting with
because everything else is done on board
so it comes on or comes with a
integrated liquid handling system so
this does all the staining also the
washing the researcher doesn't have to
actually interact with the instrument to
be able to take the sample out stain and
then wash and put it back in again this
is still an all on board here the other
thing is there's a full uh integrated
microscope as well that is smart in the
sense that it has as you can see in the
bottom image under the microscope we've
got three objectives built into the
instrument itself however the instrument
knows whether or not to employ the 2x
whether doing an overview scan or to use
one of the 20x's based on the type of
sample holder that you're using whether
looking at adherent cells or Imaging
through a slide and additionally has the
capability of keeping the sample in
Focus the whole entire time as well
again the idea being is that you just
load your samples and the antibodies
press play and then get on with your day
because everything again is not inside
the instrument and then again once you
have that you know the data and the
images are taken you can then go ahead
and work with that data which we'll
actually see later we can use automated
approaches to make this even more
streamlined
the other thing being is that giving you
the capability of doing different types
of samples is yellow as well obviously
we talked about tissue and how you know
wanting to work with maybe a couple
um of tissue slides that you have we
have this validated for multiple
fixation types so we ffpe uh PFA as well
as acetone but again not everyone may be
working with tissue and actually wants
to do multiplexing on tissue they may
want to do something with adherent cells
which is where our Maxwell 24 Imaging
plates come in so you could just culture
your cells in there fix those and then
be able to do the multiplexing in those
and then eventually we're also going to
be able to do suspension cells so if
those that are working with um those
suspension cells you can either side of
spin them into like that Max 24 or right
we can then have these little micro
Chambers where one individual cell would
fall into each one of these Chambers and
you can do the multiplexing there again
being able to run the gamut of what you
may want to actually Multiplex and get a
better understanding in terms of the
markers that are expressed on those
cells
next the other thing we do in terms of
trying to increase the efficiency of
this multiplexing space and again
lowering that barrier of people working
um with this type of Technology as we
have a list of validated antibodies so
these come from our high quality
recombinant antibodies so anyone that
has worked maybe with the reaffinity
antibodies before know that they're
really
um unique in that they are this
recombinant technology they give a lot
of lots a lot of consistency they're
highly reproducible and the other thing
being is that they're actually
engineered with a mutated fcr region so
this minimizes the background that
you're getting from that
um and also eliminating the need for use
of say an fcr blocking buffer the other
thing being is like again these are all
within our particular portfolio you'll
see that we also know that they're
erasable for this particular technique
and the nice thing is is while our
portfolio may have you know thousands
and thousands of antibodies it's not
always that we have them right but that
they also work with the technology and
that's where the second portion or the
the middle
um column talking about the extensive
mixed validated antibodies so we have
done a lot of work in-house to be able
to take the antibodies that are within
our portfolio and test them actually
with the mixed technology so making sure
that the staining
um at room temperature works right at a
certain concentration and that these
would then get the designation of a mix
um validated antibody so the nice thing
here is that you know
um of all those we've actually validated
up to 500 antigens across both the human
and the mouse we've got different clones
um for for each of these and that when
you've also taken consideration the
three different fluorophores that we use
within the technology
um well like we talked about at the
beginning of the staining with the up to
three
um antibodies that we're talking about
around 2 000 conjugates already
validated so that you can just you know
pull them off the shelf and be able to
use again increasing that efficiency of
being able to ramp up and then also
scale up your your attack or your your
um Imaging and and your particular
panels the other thing being is that
we've also have this in a couple of
optimized antibody formats we certainly
have the vials so that you can kind of
have the flexibility of going from say a
couple of antibodies eight or or 12
right up to then the hundreds that we
were talking about and really test those
out and have the flexibility of doing
what you want with the vials and which
is really nice
um however we also have a these Ria
screen plates that are more standardized
again talking about the efficiency and
being able to do this
um in a very reproducible manner as well
we have the Ria screen plates these are
again the miltoni antibodies but they
are dried down into these 96 well plates
that you see here and then uh heat oil
sealed and all you have to do is again
put the and the actual sample in there
and then put this plate in here and
everything else is done on board so
talking about really ramping up of again
just turning through samples
These are nice standardized way of being
able to have also your antibody and and
get done faster so this comes in a rear
screen Max so all the antibodies that
are validated or custom plates once you
have a panel that you want to run
through for every single
um sample that you may come across
and so while all that's great we're
talking a lot about or the efficiency of
being able to you know get the Imaging
done again everything done in the
instrument uh now it turns into what do
you do with the data afterwards right
and traditionally this has been kind of
the bottleneck in the sense that you
know a lot of automation has gone into
the Imaging portion but now you need to
be able to identify and quantify and do
things with the actual data output and I
think that's really a unique feature of
being able to have the max IQ view
analysis software along with this
package so certainly it is a great
viewer all those images that you took
and all the you know layers you can see
those together
however the real power in this becomes
the the automated detection of those
single cells right so we talked about
you know being able to get that single
cell identification kind of like you get
with flow but now we want it with the
spatial context and that's what we're
doing here so uh for those of you that
are not familiar traditionally this has
been done in a very manual way you could
either you know go ahead and circle each
one of the individual nuclei and say
that's a cell or use some other
approaches based on thresholding to kind
of say where where a nuclei is or not
however the really nice thing about the
max IQ view analysis software is that
not only we're doing you know the
traditional thresholding and histogram
that you may have used in in the past
but we're also leveraging all the
different markers that you have in the
in this um that you were able to image
in the system as well to really help and
and get better segmentation and be able
to get that better cell segmentation out
of it on top of that once you're able to
identify those individual cells like we
see on the picture on the right right
we're also able to extract all of these
features again there's no map that we
have to do the you know the instrument
is going or the sorry the software is
going to go ahead identify those and
then spit out those features so you
don't have to think about what you need
until like down look Downstream of you
know what are the different
um features or the different measures
that I want to compare for my particular
system
but it doesn't stop there because again
we may want to be able to do some
automated classification right
um particularly in this space maybe I
want to identify certain T Cell
populations and that's where this
classification within the software also
becomes a vital tool to be able to again
get to that automated identification so
that we can quantify and look at the
spatial relationships of those
and last but not least is also giving
you the capability of being able to do
some higher level
um you know um graphing or or looking at
things like a heat map for comparison so
that you can do all of this inside of
the software while also always
maintaining that back to the individual
image itself
so let's think about the different you
know automated things that we can get
out of extracting the information of
that particular biological system we
definitely can first quantify cells this
is very you know a very um common thing
that people will do in in this kind of
image analysis uh so I'm giving you just
an example we were looking at this
particular ovarian cell line uh looking
at it the under control
um situation and then a treatment and
what was very obviously just like
looking at it is that there was a big
change in the phenotypic
um you know what was happening in the
system of those that remained after
treatment were a much larger cells and
also had a lot of morphological changes
in these and so the nice thing was is
that within the software we were able to
actually map and understand you know how
big these cells were what kind of the
changes in the morphology of the nuclei
but then again coupling that to the
being able to do the multiplexing we
were also able to start looking into
what makes these cells unique
and that's where this slide comes in
we're looking at the control on the left
and the treatment on the right we've
just got a couple of markers out of this
particular study looking at dappy just
again identifying the nuclei cd44 for a
kind of the ovarian cell cancer line
marker but then you know we've got these
markers X and Y that obviously had a
very different expression in the control
and the treatment groups and it wasn't
just that we could see that there were
differences again within the software we
could actually get the software to
extract on a single cell level right all
the different
um intensity differences that we were
actually visually seeing with our eye
and that's what these are so marker X on
the left hand side marker y on the right
hand side and again each of those dots
is is an individual um sell right for
that different expression levels on the
the again the y-axis of the graph and
again now we're able to not only
visually see what's going on but also
quantify and actually put numbers to
that change that we were seeing visually
not only that we can definitely deep
phenotype so again for those that are
you know maybe not familiar right
there's going to be a lot like we talked
about in this tumor microenvironment
that we would want to be able to
understand and and you know just using
the T-cell
um immune profiling and tonsil is just
an example of how deep we can actually
get and being able to look at all these
different
um T-cell subsets so on the left-hand
side here I've just kind of you know
listed out how we think about this
definitely CD3 is a particularly good T
Cell marker that everyone looks at but
again we were looking at the subsets of
being able to get down to things like T
helper cells cytotoxic T cells even
things like memory
um T helper cells and you can see kind
of the the markers that we were looking
for in each one of those classifications
so the other nice thing again is that
within the software I can kind of make a
visual
um dating strategy I'll call it right
inside of the software so that no matter
what um sample I put in now right I can
say this is the same kind of uh
phenotype that I'm going to be looking
at for each one of those and so as an
example we just look at that first top
level of CD3
and cb45 for the T cells and then kind
of breaking them up so we can again see
that on the actual image here
um in green we've got our CD3 positive T
cells we can then see those particular T
cells broken up into T Helper and
cytotoxic T cells so now all these cells
have again been classified into those
two particular populations but the other
nice thing is again because we have all
those markers we able to even go down to
this very bottom level which a lot of
times is not looked at
um just for the lack of having those
number of markers in a particular panel
and I think the other really nice thing
is again we can definitely do this we
can visualize it on the image but we can
also get numbers out so we've got you
know the quantification again of the
number of cells the percentages of their
population this is all generated
automatically in the software and again
it's a nice thing to see that maybe
these particular cells of her interest
of your research but there's very small
portion of the population and this is
definitely what we want to be driving
towards
and last but not least is being able to
spatially map all of these different
things right that's why we're keeping
the tissue intact so we can understand
these facial interactions so I'll show
you kind of two examples again that the
software can do first is um distance
mapping so we've got here just an
example of some markers uh for for
breast cancer
um uh in this particular image so these
are cytokeratins and then the blue for
all the dappy we do the same you know I
talked about doing the T Cell gating
strategy in the previous one we can
apply that same idea here to be able to
see all the T cells which are now being
displayed on that same section but in
red
and then the other nice thing is again I
can tell the software I want to be able
to automatically make these zones and
look at the different you know something
that's very hot or very close to the
particular tumor so this will be in red
to something you know we've got a
rainbow effect into the what I'll call
further away or colder region of the
particular T cells um that when I
overlay it right white is now where my
tumor was and we can see the red all the
way out to the blue
but on top of that I can actually then
automatically just engage a heat map to
be able to see if there's any signatures
in the differences of those particular
zones we can also do this by uh doing
that same kind of gating strategy
against
um other different types of cells which
I'm not going to go too much into we
actually have a nice webinar looking at
uh the lung democarcinoma
um and how this kind of all comes
together but the idea being is that once
you date each one of these particular
cell subsets you can then make these
facial relationship between the two of
them as well
um and and be able to get a heat map
that way so just as a quick kind of a
deduction to that is that we've got the
distance for each of the tumor the T
cells the macrophages and then also
those particular populations across the
bottom of this particular heat map so
you would imagine that the deepest color
or the purple is closest and then the
red is or that deeper red color is the
furthest away so that makes sense why
we've got a diagonal
um for each of these and you know just
drawing some conclusions we see that the
T cells are actually further away than
the macrophages from particular tumor
and so again I I like to end with how
all this comes together being able to
use the all the markers that you can
automatically image but then also the
software to automatically uh detect
individual cells and make some
conclusions out of it with this example
of car T self therapy in pdac or
pancreatic ductile edema carcinoma
so for this particular paper it was part
of the mix technology was actually part
of a larger workflow too of engaging a
lot of automated devices right to really
start identifying a particular Target of
Interest so that when you get down to
the generation the car T you have a few
good targets to use but I think the
other nice thing is is you can wrap this
back around and actually look at you
know the mechanism of action in this
particular case of why maybe a treatment
worked or didn't work so just a little
introduction here we've got
um you know we started with screening a
bunch of xenographs so where we've got a
lot of tissue
um available right we can actually use
flow cytometry but that once they wanted
to work into uh primary uh pdac or
pieces of tissue they didn't have as
much so that's why the mixed technology
was very useful so they spread that
across the mix in the flow cytometry
then also looked at it in off-target
effects and the healthy tissue I and
again did the car T generation and the
actual actual validation
so here's just a quick image of like
again all of the different you know
images that you can get out for the
different markers that were actually
investigated
um but again the really nice thing is is
that once you have those you do the
Single Cell identification and then you
can get a really nice heat map out for
for each one of the cells that you've
got in all the markers so for reference
going on a down so each of the rows is
actually a individual marker and across
the top each column is actually one cell
and what they were able to do is again
identify regions where the markers of
the particular markers for the P DAC
um gave a specific region and then of
course immune cells and they were
looking for uh targets you know that
would be highly expressed in the tumor
region of this heat map but not in the
immune cells and so while it's really
great to be able to have this you know
very quick and easy way of
identification I don't think I I'd be
remiss to not also say that it's great
to have the images because not only can
you verify what you're seeing in the
heat map where you like here where we
can you know verify that cd59 was not
tumor specific because it did not
um at least overlap with the green now
for the cytokeratin which would be our
tumor and then the marker of Interest
would be in red and so this would be the
cd59
um and those that were tumor specific so
that's something like CD 318 where you
now see the green and the red overlap
very well but you can also kind of also
look if there was one that you were
unsure about or was not sure about them
you know wanted to investigate the
morphology you can also do that like in
this last example with the CLA
so once they were able to identify a
couple of targets theirs was their top
three so cd60 succeed t-span 8 and cd318
all that I'm showing here is that with
upon a um tumor microarray they were
looking at the pdac so this was the
actual uh tumor that they're looking for
but we're able to also put a bunch of
healthy tissue in that case too staying
for those particular targets and see
whether or not they were expressed on
any healthy tissue and that if they do
generate the car T you know would there
be any kind of off-target effects that
would lead to
um either decreased efficiency or you
know other dangerous effects so they
were able to at least see us at cd66c
and CD 318 did not have a lot of off
Target
um uh staining whereas t-span 8 did have
some in the colon but they were able to
use this maybe for some other or other
treatments as well so they looked at
that and generated that as well which is
the last portion of the actual car T
generation Administration so on the left
hand side we're actually looking at the
mice and looking at the the xenografts
in there and the bioluminescence for
each of those for the cd66c t-span 8 and
cd318 uh the V underneath is just a
different length of the of the linkers
on the car tee and what we can see at
least visually is that the cd66c and the
or sorry the CD 318 was very good at
being able to do the reduction of the
actual
um of the the size of the tumor we can
also get that graphically on the right
hand side and what's really stocked here
is that the difference between the cd66c
and the 318 which were the top two
Targets is that there's a marked
difference between the actual reduction
of the tumor size and that's what led to
being able to do this also in terms of
the mixed technology of looking at what
could possibly be going on in the system
as well so looking at the actual car T
Cell infiltration so for reference cd66c
will be across the top row and then
cd318 is across the bottom row and in
the first couple you're looking actually
at the car T infiltration so this is
looking at some T-cell markers so C4 and
cd8 but then the specific car T
um being labeled in the blue of the LNG
of r also making sure that they're you
know whether or not there's actually
tumor left in there what kind of you
know macrophage infiltration we get but
also since there was a question of a
possible down regulation they were also
making sure that cd66c and 318 whether
or not they're actually still expressed
and that's why the conclusion is from
here was at least there wasn't a down
regulation of the cd6 c6c that was
leading to the differences but um you
know might be something that has to be
investigated more
and so with that I'm you know I'm very
uh uh happy to take any of your
questions and I hope that this was
helpful in terms of seeing how
um you know bringing in automation into
their whole entire Imaging portfolio
um it could be really useful for
different applications that you're
working with now
thank you Dr jablonski for your
informative presentation we will now
start the Q a portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
now let's get started
our first question is can I take
advantage of my own automated analysis
pipeline in combination to the max IQ
view software
yeah so that's a great question uh you
know thinking about the max IQ view
software I think there's several ways
that you could combine on this with
existing analysis Pipelines first uh you
know there's user generated segmentation
masks people have obviously worked on
you can import these into the software
to identify the cells and then use the
you know Downstream tools that are built
in uh you know definitely also there are
features generated inside Max IQ view
that can be exported and then
um you know certain measures that you
could then use that and put into your
own statistical package and then lastly
which I didn't touch on but we actually
have the capability of importing Python
scripts that you may be already be
writing us into the software so it's
combined all into one for a really
complete workflow
great thank you for that response our
next question how many samples can be
run in the Maxima at one time
yeah so the Maxima has a total of eight
slots uh for the in the re sample and
reagent uh chamber area that I alluded
to earlier it can hold up to eight
slides at a time
typically though we run about three to
four samples
um at a time based on our antibody
panels right we're doing a lot of these
uh so that the sample doesn't sit in on
processed for an excessive amount of
time
for that
another few questions how big of a
sample or how many samples can be loaded
into the blaze
yeah so I think I should assure you guys
right that it can go really small to
even that really large you know cleared
mouth so the blaze has a large chamber
sizes which really can can accommodate
all of those without being able to need
that sectioning so our standard sample
chamber is capable of actually mounting
five cleared intact Mouse organs to be
able to do in one run we also just
released a new XXL
um chamber which actually has the
capability of fitting a whole human
organ or an adult Mouse so we were
showing you some some more
um younger mice but now we're going to
have the capability to do that
additionally right the Mosaic and batch
modes that are built into the software
actually
um give you the capability to you know
do this all and process all these
tissues uh in a single run
that's awesome thank you for that all
right we're going to wrap with this last
question
um what type of clearing methods can be
used with the blaze
yeah so I alluded to the max clearing um
kit which obviously is a great way to
get started but I know that a lot of
people that work in the kind of like
cheat
um space already have really worked a
lot on I you know optimizing their
clearing methods for their particular
um uh sample that they're working with
and the blaze is designed really to be
compatible actually with most clearing
uh techniques so just to give you a
little idea each objective actually has
a series of interchangeable dipping caps
that are corrected for the range of
refractive index um indexes and ab a
numbers that corresponds with most of
these different Imaging Solutions that
you may be working with not only that we
also have a refractive index adjustment
collar that you can make minor changes
to as well to match better to your the
refractive index of your Imaging
solution but I think the really nice
thing you know talking about the
automation built then is that the blaze
is fully automated and makes these fun
these more minor or fine adjustments in
the light sheet and the Imaging objects
to really correct for the spherical and
uh chromatic aberrations
um that you might be seeing so I think
it's kind of the best of all worlds
where you can use what you're use um
you're used to but then you can also
take advantage of some of those features
really to optimize that and be able to
have the best of those worlds with that
thank you Dr jablonski do you have any
final comments for our audience
I don't thank you for the opportunity
and I hope everyone found this uh
informative
thank you so much again for your time
today and your important research before
we go I'd like to just thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions I'd also
like to thank our sponsor miltony
biotech for sponsoring today's webinar
questions we didn't have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until May 18 2024. lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with any of your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye